right he's gonna help you with your
brackets and Howie swab set to join us
on loan from Fox Sports they're college
basketball brass bracket expert Howard
good morning thanks for joining us what
stood out to you yesterday well first of
all great to be with you Dan and the
Janet's excited to be back on but what
stood out to me a couple of things
number one this was the toughest year to
figure out the bracket it really was
because there's such balance in college
basketball some people say it's great
some people say it's mediocrity I think
it's just been a fun year what stood out
very simply I thought there were two
teams that made the tournament that
surprised make Arizona State and
Syracuse Arizona State got in because
they beat save here in Kansas they
didn't get in because of the way they
played down the stretch 8 and 11 last 19
games one in five last six games lost at
home to Stanford Utah and Oregon and
those are three teams that didn't make
the tournament so I was surprised
Arizona State got in but because of
those two big wins there in Stara Cuse I
found to be surprising as well I
personally had Saint Mary's in USC in
but they didn't have enough big ones st.
Mary's only beat Gonzaga and USC didn't
have as many quality wins as some other
teams though USC finished second and the
pac-12 made the finals of the pac-12
tournament but didn't get enough of a
boost by beating Oregon and Oregon State
the pac-12 tournament so now we move on
the other thing that amazed me Duke
Kansas and Michigan State or all in the
same region crazy gonna be that's why
you're ruff why is that Holly why is
that well because Michigan State's a 3
seed the fact that the committee
downplayed Michigan State is fascinating
because I personally think Michigan
State when the whole thing actually I'm
picking Michigan State to win the whole
thing I think that this week off will
actually help them
Big Ten tournament being played a little
earlier this year it's going to be
interesting to see how that affects
Michigan Ohio State and Michigan State
and Purdue
how did Oklahoma get in Oklahoma got in
because of strength of the body of work
overall certainly not the way they
finished 4 and 11 the last 15 games they
really struggled Trey young hit a wall
and while he had a great year certainly
Oklahoma down the stretch was a very big
question mark
Oklahoma State beat them twice Oklahoma
State beat them in the big 12 tournament
it's kind of surprising but yet Oklahoma
plays Rhode Island in the first round
being away from the big 12 teams that
know Oklahoma so well it's possible
Oklahoma could give Rhode Island a tough
game it's an interesting matchup though
Rhode Island has a lot of veteran
players and they're looking to bounce
back they lost to Davidson in in their
tournament in the a-10 what is your best
bracket advice for people don't
overthink it because a lot of times
people look for the big upset I think a
lot of the times in the tournament
you're gonna see chalk end up coming
through there have been a few years
where there been a lot of surprises I'm
in the year Connecticut and Kentucky met
in the final as seven and eight seeds
was pretty wild but I think that you're
gonna see a lot of chalk now come
through because it's college basketball
the better teams and appointee that's
why you don't see a 16 beatable one for
example give me the number one seed or
number two see the first top seed to go
out you know what I think Kansas well
Kansas their bracket could be
interesting I like Virginia and
Villanova to get a little Final Four so
those two won seats I think we'll be
okay
xaviar will be challenged I think Savior
will be challenged by Gonzaga I think
most of the one seeds will be okay so
you have Michigan State going to the
Final Four
you have Virginia going to the Final
Four yeah building OVA going to the
Final Four and your other team is good
Gonzaga out of that bracket and I'll
tell you what a lot of people are on
Michigan in that bracket
watch out Michigan Montana is not a bad
team Michigan with the week off they had
all the momentum in the world after what
they did in the Big Ten tournament
beating the likes of Purdue Michigan
State Nebraska
that's three pretty solid wins Nebraska
has had a really good team that ends up
in the NIT do you think it's just a
coincidence Howie that you had these
teams under investigation that were on
the bubble that didn't make the
tournament with USC and Oklahoma State
they don't get in Louisville conspiracy
theorists will definitely talk about
that and then you'll argue back or burn
in Arizona got seeded lower than some
people thought I thought over and was
seated right because I'll burn
unfortunately fell apart down the
stretch a lot of injuries Arizona I
could see where they see them I
personally see them as the three they
got see it as a four that's okay it's
interesting Oklahoma State when you look
at what they accomplished you beat
Kansas twice you beat Oklahoma twice you
want it West Virginia beat Texas Tech
you beat Florida State on a
quote-unquote neutral court was in
Florida I think you can make a real good
case because the argument of strength of
schedule well they also played Wichita
State and Arkansas you know non league
too so I mean Oklahoma State ma yeah if
you want to penalize a team for not
playing a tough schedule fine but
Oklahoma State the one criteria that
killed in those RPI well that's only a
tool
I mean look look at what they
accomplished beating Kansas twice is a
great feat
no one else did that I just look at what
Oklahoma State did and and the committee
comes up with criteria and then goes
against the criteria so to me the
committee can decide whatever they want
Oklahoma State fans have every right to
be upset with this st. Mary's in USC I
thought it also had an alleged complaint
but you know that's why college
basketball is great there are people who
say oh expand the tournament know all
these seams should be in no absolutely
not 68 is just fine you know it's J it's
enough I thought when they expanded 64
to 68 I thought they were wrong but you
know what it's okay at 68 it's fine how
a good to talk to you we'll talk to you
during the tournament now working for
Fox Sports college basketball bracket
expert Howie Schwab but Pauly wanted to
know is there a sports topic a sports
trivia topic that would be your
wheelhouse that you would dominate uh
college basketball I love college
basketball I'm really passionate about
that more as much as anything I've
really enjoyed being involved with
college hoops and yeah Pauly I love the
idea of walking around in jerseys do you
what's your favorite college basketball
trivia question oh well it's hard to say
I mean I could throw out a bunch of
different things I mean one I'll throw
out right now is named the three teams
that have made the tournament at least
20 straight years in a row before this
year well actually now it's four because
Gonzaga is the fourth but they made it
torture that's not seven twenty or more
straight years in the tournament just
Gonzaga and that was the fourth so Duke
is there Lucas
Duke is there yep North Carolina nope
it's tough Kentucky nope mmm
consecutive years 20 or more okay okay
oh this is tougher than I thought
the answer is Kansas and Michigan State
or the other tooth no I think I would
have gotten there he balances I I don't
know if I would have thought of Michigan
State hmm yeah no it's well Tom Izzo's
great at this time of year so that's I'm
gonna go with him I think they will
bounce back after the loss to Michigan
on the Big Ten Tournament Paulie has
Paulie wants to try to stump the swamp
Paulie yeah oh boy I don't know what's
gonna work it Howie this is kind of
wheelhouse for you
Michigan State versus our versus Indiana
State for the title in 1979 79 yep who
did Indiana State beat to advance to the
final game they won by two points oh oh
I know that the final four was Indiana
State against DePaul yes ten against
Michigan State Michigan State beat Penn
by 50 and Penn beat Saint John's in the
game before which still bothers me
wasn't Gary Garland was he one of the
stars of that DePaul team yup and Carl
Nicks and some guy named bird yeah yeah
yeah that was me can't stole yeah I know
that 79 I was that was that was a really
vintage year for college basketball and
I was a very important year for college
basketball and burden magic certainly
were very important for the TV no change
College Wars can be changed it yep hey
how we good to talk to you as always and
have fun during the tournament hey
Paulie thanks for giving me an easy
enough questioning and I love going on
and thanks guys I appreciate it that's
how he's Schwalm stump to Schwalm for
more Dan Patrick show to the audience
Channel 239 on DirecTV or download the
Dan Patrick show at
you